[Musique]
alors ça y est à 22h21 radio canada
prévoit que le prochain gouvernement
libéral sera finalement minoritaire donc
justin trudeau à la tête d'un
gouvernement minoritaire il recrée
exactement ce que son père avait fait 68
dos majorité et en 72 minorité à ta voix
donc l'histoire qui se répète avec son
fils gouvernement minoritaire la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est
sera-t-il parce qu'on voyait venir ça
depuis un bon moment mais sera-t-il
confortablement minoritaire ou vraiment
minoritaires passez moi l'expression sur
la fesse la cas il devra avec
l'instabilité
parce que le npd n'est pas assez élevé
rita pour se rendre à 170 pour les